après des heures d'anxiété le
soulagement de revoir des proches
maintenant sécurité c'est au compte
gouttes que des dizaines de milliers
d'ukrainiens traversent la frontière
après un long et difficile voyage pour
fuir la guerre
altor booth un trajet en voiture un
autre en autobus et enfin huit heures de
marche voilà le parcours de ces femmes
qui viennent une ville pourtant située à
seulement 80 km de la pologne
on se trouve à quelques centaines de
mètres à peine de l'ukraine et vous
voyez les gens ne cesse d'entrer en
pologne en attendant parfois de longues
heures de très longues heures une
famille nous a dit même avoir attendu 20
heures avant de pouvoir entrer dans ce
pays de l'union européenne pour y
trouver refuge et une fois que les
réfugiés et craignait arrive en pologne
les besoins sont très grands que ce soit
en voiture ou à pied les scénarios sont
semblables à tous les points d'entrée
tous les modes de transport sont bons
pour s'éloigner du conflit armé cette
gare à une quinzaine de kilomètres de la
frontière accueillira retrait qui est
encore l'ukraine une station devenue un
centre d'accueil pour accompagner des
centaines de réfugiés
bat a rejoint
johnny
dany attendaient dès sa mère qui a de la
difficulté à quitter le pays mais elle
ne sait pas quand elle pourra y arriver
en plus de la tante de parfois 24 heures
au poste frontalier les déplacements
sont compliquées ces congolais installés
en ukraine l'ont bien constater les
routes sont prises d'assaut pour
atteindre la frontière la marche si
finalement imposée je marchais presque
20 km s'il n'y avait pas des transports
les ukrainiens étaient là bas leur
chauffeur disais bon on s'arrête ici la
bayanne embouteillages il n'y a pas
moyen de continuer mehdi s'est rendu en
ukraine il y a deux ans à la recherche
d'une vie meilleure il doit maintenant
fuir un conflit nous avons vu des
histoires qu'on n'a jamais vu des gens
mourir comme ça dans le président et
je sais pas si j'ai le regret de ma vie
ils sont nombreux ici à ne pas savoir ce
qui les attend combien de temps
resteront ils pourront ils trouver un
logement afin de les aider les autorités
polonaises et une armée de bénévoles
sont mobilisés pour mira l'idée d'aider
à distribuer de la nourriture s'est
rapidement imposé cette polonaise
d'origine ukrainienne dit avoir la
difficulté à s'exprimer
des gens viennent littéralement de
l'enfer dit elle tania ne pouvait pas
s'imaginer que la russie puisse attaquer
sont payés de cette manière
que du coup ça chez nous
pis met en colère solidarité peur et
incompréhension à la frontière entre la
pologne et l'ukraine se croisent des
peuples et leurs émotions ici rappelle
nous dit auclair radio canada medica